yo pinto su habitación a una tasa de 8
metros cuadrados por hora después de
tres horas pintando le faltaban y esto
es algo muy importante le faltaban por
pintar 28 metros cuadrados
aquí está hablándonos en términos de el
restante que quedaba por pintar verdad
no es el total que lleva pintado sino lo
que le falta por pintar muy bien sea adt
el área por pintar justamente coincide
con lo anterior verdad
adt es el área por pintar donde o con
una medida en metros cuadrados como
función del tiempo t y éste está medido
en horas y nos pide el ejercicio
escribir la fórmula de la función muy
bien así que pongamos algunos puntos
para que esto sea un poco más tangible
muy bien pensemos para que podamos
pensar bien a la función a en términos
del tiempo muy bien entonces vamos a
hacer una tablita aquí
ok tenemos una tabla y digamos que aquí
tenemos t que está medido en horas y
aquí vamos a poner como función del
tiempo medido en metros cuadrados muy
bien entonces nosotros no tenemos mucha
información la información con la que
contamos es esta verdad que después de
tres horas pintando le faltaban le
faltaban por pintar 28 metros cuadrados
muy bien entonces no sabemos cuántos
metros cuadrados tiene su habitación que
sería digamos al tiempo cero ni al
tiempo uno sabemos ni el tiempo 2 pero
si sabemos al tiempo 3 al tiempo 3 y por
supuesto este es esto está medido en
horas en 3 horas después de haber
pintado durante tres horas nos quedan a
giros le quedan 28 metros cuadrados por
pintar muy bien
así que una pregunta interesante es
cuánto tendría le digamos pendiente por
pintar a la segunda ahora digamos
digamos que queremos analizar esto por
ejemplo cuánto le quedaba por pintar
después de dos horas de estar pintando
ya y hay que pensarlo muy bien por
ejemplo a las tres horas le quedaban por
pintar 28 metros cuadrados muy bien a
las dos horas cuál será serán algo más
de 28 o menos de 28 metros cuadrados por
pintar y hay que pensar muy bien verdad
porque la tasa a la que está pintando es
de 8 metros cuadrados por hora verdad
eso quiere decir que a medida que avance
el tiempo a medida que avanza el tiempo
a medida que avance el tiempo tenemos
menos menos metros cuadrados por pintar
verdad pues si lo vamos pintando un
cuarto cada vez nos quedan menos por
pintar verdad es decir si el tiempo
aumenta tenemos menos metros cuadrados
restantes así que aquí tendría que ser
más
metros cuadrados por pintar verdad
porque no hemos pintado lo suficiente
como en tres horas así que aquí lo que
tenemos que hacer es aumentar los ocho
metros cuadrados verdad
tendríamos que sumarle a 28 y ocho
justamente y eso nos da 36 muy bien
vamos a ver qué pasaría por ejemplo si
tuviéramos que si tuviéramos a hero
pintando durante una hora nada más
durante una hora bueno pues a 36
tendríamos que sumarle 8 metros verdad y
esos son 44 muy bien y vamos a hacer con
otro color digamos que el giro apenas va
a ponerse a pintar es decir el número de
horas que ha pintado es cero entonces
cuál es el área que le resta por pintar
es decir cuál es el área de la
habitación cierto entonces a 44
nuevamente le sumamos 8 y eso nos da 52
muy bien así que ahora vamos a pensar si
todo esto tiene sentido por ejemplo si
nosotros vamos
pero aún no estamos haciendo un cambio
en el tiempo de una hora muy bien como
sería el cambio del área por pintar el
cambio sería el cambio del área por
pintar sería igual a pues vamos de 52 a
44 eso son menos 8 verdad sería 44 menos
52 eso justamente nos da menos 8 lo cual
tiene sentido que sea negativo verdad
porque cada vez nos queda menos metros
cuadrados por pintar y además ya
sabíamos que giro pinta a una taza de 8
metros cuadrados por hora muy bien
así que todo esto fue bastante
interesante ahora veamos si podemos
construir la fórmula y la ventaja que
tenemos en este problema es que nosotros
sabemos que pinta a una tasa constante y
eso es importante porque cuando tenemos
una función a tasa constante quiere
decir que es una función lineal verdad
entonces el área de el área de la
habitación que resta por pintar es igual
a m por t más una constante b donde m
sabemos que es la pendiente de esta
línea que representa la función verdad o
bien es la tasa de cambio por otro lado
b b es la ordenada al origen es decir a
donde intersecta esta línea con con el
eje vertical cierto entonces la
pendiente nosotros sabemos muy bien
cuánto vale vale menos 8 verdad menos 8
porque aquí ya lo vimos el cambio nada
es más vamos a escribirlo la pendiente
el cambio en el área restante por pintar
dividido entre el cambio en el tiempo y
eso es menos 8 dividido entre 1 que es
exactamente menos 8 entonces la
pendiente es menos 8 ahora bien nos
falta determinar quién es b es decir la
ordenada al origen pero eso es muy fácil
verdad porque nosotros sabemos que
cuando te vale 0 bueno entonces de este
lado esto esto simplemente se cancela y
nos queda que ha evaluado en 0 es b y
eso ya vimos que es 52 así que podemos
concluir fácilmente quién es nuestra
función a dt es igual a la pendiente que
en este caso es menos 8 x t que es el
tiempo
52 más 52 muy bien aquí ya tenemos la
fórmula verdad de hecho podríamos
justamente verificar que 52 es a
evaluado en 0 porque ha evaluado en 0 es
menos 8 por 0 que es 0 más b y esto era
justamente aquí lo tenemos es 52 muy
bien perfecto entonces ahora lo que
podríamos hacer es observar que en
efecto las unidades están bien dadas es
decir todos estamos hablando de metros
cuadrados y eso lo podemos ver de la
siguiente forma bueno
adt adt es igual a la tasa verdad la
tasa la tasa es el cambio del área
restante por pintar dividido entre el
tiempo esos son metros cuadrados
dividido entre horas verdad entonces
esto es menos ocho metros cuadrados y
aquí voy a escribirlo completo
entre horas o menos 8 metros cuadrados
por horas y esto multiplica el tiempo
verdad el tiempo son t horas muy bien
entonces justamente aquí podemos ver que
se van a cancelar y luego sumamos 52
pero 52 está dado en metros cuadrados
verdad porque son los metros cuadrados
que le restan por pintar al tiempo cero
muy bien entonces tenemos metros
cuadrados aquí del lado izquierdo las
horas se cancelan y tendríamos menos 8 t
metros cuadrados más 52 metros cuadrados
entonces justamente adt está dado en
metros cuadrados como aquí nos lo
solicitaba ahora bien otra forma de
resolver este problema es de la
siguiente forma nosotros sabemos que a
de t es igual a una pendiente que sería
menos ocho por t más una constante
verdad menos ocho ya lo sabemos
justamente por esta información sólo hay
que tener mucho cuidado
no ponerlo positivo verdad porque
recordemos que a dt es el área por
pintar es decir es lo que nos falta por
por terminar de pintar digamos verdad y
esto es qué tan rápido pinta giro en la
habitación ahora bien lo único que nos
falta es determinar ve y ahí podemos
utilizar esta información después de
tres horas pintando le faltaban por
pintar 28 metros cuadrados y eso lo
podemos usar fácilmente aquí verdad
porque si por ejemplo ponemos de igual a
3 de igual a 3 es justamente usar esta
información cuando t es igual a 3 a dt
es 28 esto es 28 y por supuesto aquí te
valdría 3 entonces lo que tenemos es 28
igual a menos 8 por 3 que son menos 24
más ve muy bien podemos sumar 24 de
ambos lados sumamos 24 de ambos lados y
qué es lo que tenemos 28 más 24 son
justamente 4 y 8 son 12 y llevamos 1
dos y dos son cuatro y una son cinco
estos se cancelan y del lado derecho
simplemente nos queda ve entonces
justamente ve vale 52 que era justamente
lo que ya habíamos obtenido
anteriormente así que a mí a mí me gusta
mucho hacerlo también de esta última
forma para confirmar que hemos resuelto
muy bien el problema